okay I mentioned this idea of ben Carson
being used as a sort of prop as a black
guy in the Trump campaign because Trump
is rallying hard to try to get up above
zero percent favorability with the black
vote and um Chris Wallace from Fox News
Sunday every once in a while Chris
Wallace will actually ask a pretty good
question and he had ben Carson on and in
this case the question was do you feel
that you're being used as a prop because
of your race to help Donald Trump pander
to black voters in the midst of what is
a disastrous situation for Donald Trump
where his favorability in a recent PPP
poll among black voters was not even
high enough to register one percent so
uh Chris Wallace asks ben Carson about
this some people believe that the
question itself was very very offensive
and racist we'll talk about that but
first I want to play the clip for you
question do you know what do you worry
that you're being used as a prop for
black voters and the supporting Donald
Trump will end up hurting your
credibility in the black community me
it's a long time ago it's not about me
it's about our nation but I would
suggest Chris go back and look at the
1995 state of the union address by Bill
Clinton and see what he said he said
illegal aliens are creating big problems
for us and we're going to put a lot more
Border Patrol people on and secure our
borders and we're not going to have
people able to work or come in illegally
and we're going to cut off their welfare
benefits and we're going to deport
people and record numbers you know he
says vick is basically the same thing
but when he says it wow great standing
ovation this is a great president when
Trump says it it's hate speech yeah are
you being used as a prop to pander to
black voters do you have any idea what
Bill Clinton said about immigration
during the nineteen ninety-five state of
the union address this is sometimes I
praise politicians for pivoting really
well and you have to throw in phrases
like that's a really great question and
at the heart of this issue is insert
completely unrelated issue right that's
like one way
in which skilled politicians know how to
pivot away uh ben Carson not hiding the
pivot saying oh well let's talk about
the 1995 State of the Union address not
that what he's talking about is a
illegitimate because we've actually seen
Trump's rhetoric has been very extreme
on that issue but really many
Republicans and Democrats have have
relatively similar positions on that but
Carson just failing to pivot in any kind
of credible way here didn't he yeah what
does he have to lose here his luggage
maybe knows he could he could use
anything and I I kind of like this guy
now for either sit a small place in my
heart for him with his is dodgy have is
dodgy ways I find it incredibly
entertaining and a absolute disaster is
the potential leader of the free world
so here's the issue I want to really dig
into I got some emails from people who
said David it's insulting to ask ben
Carson if he's being used as a prop to
pander to black voters because the
question implies that he would
potentially even allow himself to be
used as a prop which is very insulting
with a white person ever be asked are
you being used to pander to white voters
listen if you have a black uh candidate
in a completely white district and every
single one of the people that are
tagging along with you are white I think
it would be perfectly legitimate and it
should be asked to the white supporters
are you being pulled in here because
this is a black candidate who's
struggling in a white district I don't
think that there would be a double
standard in that that's number one but
let me actually go further than that
Donald Trump is polling 0% favorability
with black voters and he goes to Detroit
with ben Carson and Omarosa okay to a
black church and dances I think if
anyone didn't ask whether these were
campaign props they would not be doing
their job I find nothing offensive about
the question and I think it is the exact
right question for Chris Wallace to be
asking here because this is obvious
pandering yeah too obvious they have the
chance to actually once again hit this
out of the park and he doesn't dance
yeah doesn't sing he loses his luggage
he talks about Bill Clinton they're just
just nothing to it Donald Trump had
three black people with him on this trip
who apparently loved him well I don't
know if Katrina Pearson was on the trip
but she was you know running running
interference as far as PR goes Katrina
Pearson Omarosa and Ben Carson thus
obviously black Americans would just do
fantastic under Trump they would finally
win again I don't know who you're going
to convince with this nonsense and
what's great is the polls are actually
reflecting that and what I really find
to be that the the bigotry that we hear
is the right will often say you know
Democrats are so bigoted towards black
people because they just assume they'll
have the black vote actually that's not
true it's very very clear that black
voters are paying attention to what
different candidates are saying the
obvious pandering that should work if
that if if black voters are so liable to
be influenced by pandering then you
would actually see Trump's numbers with
black voters improving based on the
pandering and it's not happened so
they're actually like most groups that
we look at whether it's Latino voters
whether it's women who also are
absolutely horrified of Trump although
not to the same degree is black people
these groups are actually paying
attention and I think that's the biggest
thing that we are learning from the
Trump pander fest to Detroit Michigan